veíamos en el servicio fúnebre que
hablaron cuatro mujeres dos de ellas
afro y de hecho Patricia Yanet baronesa
de Escocia fue la primera en hablar
incluso antes que la primera brinista la
primera ministra británica
es una de la secretarias generales de la
commonwealth y también habló otra afro
ella es shermara fletcher oficial
principal de relaciones pentecostales y
carismáticas de las iglesias de
Inglaterra Carolina La pregunta es Cómo
interpretar políticamente la
participación de estas mujeres tanto de
la como Wells y de las iglesias
británicas en este cortejo fúnebre
es muy buena pregunta si bien podemos
ver que en la audiencia no hay quizás
tantas mujeres que hayan hablado todas
mujeres que haya abierto elegido una
Primer Ministro mujer y despidiendo a
una monarca mujer que claramente Marcar
a la historia del Reino Unido para para
siempre es toda una simbología
que no se no se va a volver a repetir en
los próximos al menos 50 años dado que
la línea de sucesión tiene varios
hombres en el medio Pero pero bueno sí
es muy representativo y es es un es un
detalle muy muy importante a remarcar
[Música]